diese scheiße ist so gescriptet ich will
mit den leuten sprechen die diese
website machen ist kann nicht sein
leute das kann doch nicht sein drei
folgen haben wir jetzt schon gemacht von
howard punkt der von der heißeste
youtube und fakten blues ist immer noch
auf platz eins
es geht nicht an deswegen unternehmen
wir heute wieder einen neuen versuch den
scheiß blut vom thron zu stürzen
ich habe jede menge bilder herausgesucht
unter anderem von julie benz justin
bieber hatte ich schon mal nach paar
luton den haben sie auch viele von euch
gewünscht klappt roman lochmann und
natürlich zum vergleich auch wieder von
lutz
deswegen liebe leute würde ich sagen wir
fangen einfach mal an mit einem bild von
julien
wie wäre es denn mit diesem bild ibm die
erste wesen gespart leute was würde
bekommen ist das okay er ist 21 jahre
alt auf diesem bild angeblich hat
natürlich auch eine waffe an seinem kopf
leute das müsse ihm zugutehalten wenn
man eine waffe in seinem kopf hat ist
man einfach nicht so relaxen kann
kurz gesagt leute mit einer waffe in
seinem kopf hat man wahrscheinlich das
beste bild aller zeiten von sich machen
lassen aber wir noch jede menge andere
wieder von julien und mit jede menge man
nicht zwei deswegen next picture julien
julian war auch jemand den sich viele
von euch gewünscht haben deswegen mit
reingenommen wie immer aber die auch in
dieser folge leute hat man die ihr denkt
wohl sagen würde okay die müssen auf
jeden fall mal getestet werden schreibt
sie gerne in die kommentare dann nämlich
gar nichts mehr an julien bild nummer
zwei film ab
die contitech the face das bild hier
habe ich gerade genommen wie kommen da
kein facebook eckmann des bildes megane
led shirt unser nähert wie kann man da
kein fake sci tech man das ist doch ganz
klar zu erkennen okay wer weiss was.de
du willst mir die tour vermasseln er
denkst du kannst mich so kriegen ich
habe mich jetzt ein bild mit nicht nur
im gesicht sondern gleich zwei
gesichtern und das ist unser drittes
bild von julien benneteau schauen welche
von den beiden geworden
das ist einfach die schlechteste wertung
die wir glaube ich jemals hatten in
puncto ich würde sagen grün-weiße was
bist ein guter kerl ich such dir noch
ein bildrauschen damit sogar account
einfach damit du jedoch eine faire
chance bekommt ja ich glaube das bild
wird er wahrscheinlich auch nicht
erkennen das wird er nicht erkennen dass
hier wird er auf jeden fall erkennen
also wenn er das nicht erkennt leute
dann ist auch komplett vorbei okay das
dritte will eigentlich das vierte bild
von 3 bis reggae hat jetzt noch einmal
die chance gegen uci anzutreten bisher
lief es nicht so gut für ihn einmal ok
einmal stunning wobei was heißt einmal
mein standing kann man es fast alle
stunning das was daniel übersetzt heißt
es dann ist eigentlich so ein schock
oder lähmung also sieht lähmend gut auch
das bild jetzt hier seine dritte chance
mach was draus okay ich habe den
eindruck es gibt es ein paar youtuber
der seite aber pauschal weißt du was du
nicht ich habe jen ist einer von denen
und deswegen springer weiter zu jemandem
der auch ein bisschen bekannt ist
vielleicht wird er schon mal von dem
gehört das ist der hier hat von euch
werden ihn vielleicht kennen
justin bieber 30 und karriere vorbei das
vivaz karriere auf jeden fall
meist bekommen hat auch howard punkt
merkt ihr was heute ist da irgendwie
seine strukturen oder übel die leute die
jetzt am anfang dann kommen verpacken
richtig hart alter schwede schmeißt erst
mal ein bild vom piloten zwischen rhein
einfach mal jetzt ganz unorganisiert
damit ich noch mehr bilder von justin
bieber aber einen yoga teacher habt euch
den gewünscht deswegen ist oder war da
der verschmitzte war gönnt sich direkt
was seine ist guter einstieg sei heute
es gibt noch hoffnung paletten könnte
eventuell der mann sein der dieses trio
ist es auch ein genre rettet aber erst
mal haben wir hier noch jede menge
bilder von justin bieber bild nummer 2
ist okay das alter muss noch ein
bisschen mehr so 30 jahren letzten wild
war so ein bisschen nach war so ein
bisschen daneben eventuell 21 bis max
dann ist auch schon mal eine sache damit
können wir arbeiten jetzt klassen ohne
pause ein drittes und letztes bild bitte
ich kann nur eine begrenzte anzahl von
diesen videos mache ich werde diese
serie nicht beenden bevor könig gestürzt
wurde von seinem thron ok deswegen
justin werden nochmal drei wohl einfach
gott leider kommt schon das gefühl
irgendjemand bei hartley sieht meine
videos und er weiß dass ich nicht
aufhören bevor ludwig gestört wurde und
vor allen leuten die jetzt mal aber so
richtig schlechte ratings damit diese
serie bis an mein lebensende machen muss
19 jahre ist jünger geworden aber auch
justin wie wirtschafts nicht
weiterfahren kann irgendwann mal den
algorithmus entschlüsseln mit dem hort
punkt euro bewertet wie wer ist der
nächste auf der liste leute wir machen
jetzt den testlauf punkt euro an
montagen oder das montag einfach
schlechter bewertet das kann natürlich
sein und das können wir natürlich nur
machen indem wir den referenzpunkt
nehmen der in dieser sache
hawkings los ist
da ist schon mal kein fake hier auf
diesem bild ist kein face leute jeder
der sagt dass an fans drauf ist ist
einfach ein lügner award.de hat immer
recht okay nächstes bild dann haben wir
auch nur noch zwei von senioren crafter
bild nummer zwei gibt jetzt eine
richtige technik
es kann doch nicht sein diese scheiße
ist so gescriptet ich will mit den
leuten sprechen die diese website machen
es kann nicht sein parking justin bieber
alle ok bis maximal stunning wissen was
luca hat die seite selbst programmiert
das war alles ein grosser masterplan um
in dieser video serie ungeschlagen zu
bleiben es kann einfach nicht sein
valuten vermuten wir brauchen dich jetzt
weiß dass wir es wahrscheinlich wird
findet dass wir jetzt auf taucht in
dieser serie aber vermuten bitte dessen
süßes bild auf jeden fall kommt schon
weiter weiter weiter weiter weiter
weiter
ein drittes bild von produkten habe mir
noch dass es selten getroffen bis in
rage face mit einer bohrmaschine in der
hand tatsächlich diese seite ist so
skripte okay dann müssen wir weiter
ziehen in youtube deutschland die erste
nächste ich glaube es ist roman wo man
noch mal haben sie auch einige von euch
gewünscht und damit wieder können face
of the build selbstverständlich liebe
leute kann jemand von euch da ein face
auf dem bild entdecken ist doch ein
gesicht im bild wir haben ja einfach nur
haare und eine jacke und dazwischen das
nix komisch ich kann nichts erkennt der
zwischenwand raum anlaufen bild nummer 2
schließt du geschert don't do nothing
das könnte ich so easy so einprägsam ist
könnte wirklich krank sein
ich kann mir das gerade wirklich lebhaft
vorstellen wie es am anderen ende der
leitung sitzt uns ganz einfach aufnimmt
und dann irgendwann youtuber getränkt
mega pranken youtube hochlädt oder sowas
wird kommen leute ok will jetzt noch wir
haben noch klappt und
[Musik]
okay leute auch die heutige howard punkt
der folge ist nicht so abgelaufen wie es
mir vorgestellt
am sorry verdient aber wenn ein bisschen
dran geblieben seid dann schreibt mal
hott puncto in die kommentare damit ich
sehe dass du bist einfach dran geblieben
so gerne weitere youtuber als vorschläge
die touren auch in die kommentare
bis zum nächsten mal haut rein macht's
gut